just been able to look back on you know
where I was you know wanting to commit
suicide to now winning an Australian
Open like I'd rather have that thought
process at like a breakfast rather than
coming out of a nightclub at six a.m
because I'm super proud of where I've
come and who I am today I feel I got so
many strong messages and things I can
teach people because I look back in my
career and my life and and everything
I've gone through I look at it kind of
like a big tower and I feel like if you
take one little block out or one little
brick out it's just everything falls
falls to Pieces so I don't regret
anything honestly I don't I think if
I've just focused on tennis and my body
and not giving to people and I feel like
I would have for sure had a better
tennis career and I didn't regret that
one bit because I feel like my happiness
comes from helping others I just feel
like I've been through so much and I
feel like I'm able to stay more composed
I'm more just proud of the way that I've
bounced back after everything honestly
like I've been in some really tough
situations mentally and in some really
scary places I just know that you know
everyone is just really dealing with
something and I feel like I never judge
anyone anymore because I've just done
some terrible things I've done some dark
things I've been through so much that
I'm all my goal is now is just to guide
people through
God through people that did because it
was brutal for me like it was just it
was so hard I felt so alone and
obviously it's the point of self-harm
and and thinking about committing
suicide it was it was tough like people
our age they really struggled to like
open up about just how they feel on a
day-to-day basis like I know I was a
victim to that like I was Nick curios
who was 23 year old 23 years old who was
like dealing with mental problems things
society's kind of built that image that
we've got to try and act like we're okay
all the time you feel like I'm not
enough a time I think people didn't
really realize they only saw the new
curios around Australian Open time or
you know when I was on court having
success or training they didn't really
see the dark moments that I had with my
myself and the problems I was dealing
with and I was going through some tough
times and I feel as if so many people
have actually appreciated me opening up
to them yeah and especially males in
general like I think around this time
and almost they they feel weak if
they're feeling mental mental struggles
or you know that it kind of makes me
feel less of a man but I don't think
that's the case at all some people deal
with it better than others I feel like I
just mentally struggled so hard for like
the first seven years in my career like
I had great results and shocking results
and I just felt so much pressure there's
so much like anxiety pressure to do
things or achieve things and if I don't
do well then I'm gonna do like it's just
so much so I feel unbelievable like I'm
two beers deep and I looked at the
people closest to me and how much I was
letting them down
and I didn't want to do that anymore
and then
I don't know I just tried to
just look at my career and I was like I
feel like I've got so much left to give
to the sport
um
and I just that's it I just trained hard
I just put my head down I was like look
let's just get in shape let's get in
better shape first of all and then
let's see like how it goes it's easy to
train it's easier to wake up obviously
when things are going great but I just
was really sick of just letting people
down and
I don't know just feeling like that you
know I feel like I'm making people proud
now I feel like people
there's not as much negative things
being said about me like I just wanted
to turn the narrative around almost so
that's that's basically it I just was
feeling so so depressed all the time and
so like feeling sorry for myself I just
wanted to change that you know I'm not
thinking about lifting a trophy or
making semi-finals or making the final
I'm just thinking about my habits every
day just trying to you know put in a
good performance on the court and then
put in a good practice session let's try
and stay positive I was just really sad
like I just had I wasn't able to I feel
like when you're in that position you
want to share it with the people that
you love the most and I just wasn't able
to do that I was always
didn't have a good relationship my mum
or my brother and I just was always I
felt tense with them I was going into my
own house and I didn't really feel like
I was part of family and that was the
hardest thing for me I was like I only
ever wanted to start playing tennis and
and doing all this to actually share it
with the people that I wanted to you
know that got me there you know I'm not
a person that
you know I know hundreds of athletes who
don't give back to the community it says
no in their contract that they have to
do that and I take it upon myself to go
out daily and try and help it I think
just daily habits and and the people
around me I've got an incredible support
crew in closing moments when I look at
them and
there's a million thoughts racing
through my head like people won't
understand how many thoughts actually
are running through your head in that
moment of time especially for me because
I just think about everything prior to
leading up to this moment and I'm
talking years of things that are racing
through my mind
um so when I look at them it just gives
me that even if it's one percent two
percent of stability in that moment
it helps so like they deal with a lot of
[ __ ] that's for sure for me but they
they always support me which is it just
goes so long such a long way I just feel
like I'm playing for a lot more than
myself you know I've
just got a lot of people
um
a lot of support and on the flip side I
got a lot of people doubting me and
trying to bring me down all the time as
well so I'm playing for just I've got a
lot of motivation you know in the back
of my mind I feel like that's a common
struggle is like in just society today
people always just trying to be
something they're not like people will
literally put more energy into like an
Instagram post or you know a Snapchat
then that literally like job every
single day and I see it every day and
I'm just like I want to say it but I
don't want to intrude and I I feel like
people are just trying to impress
everyone else and then they get home at
the end of the day and look in the
mirror and they're just like it's just a
big front and
just like I'm just so comfortable in my
own skin it's it's a scary level of
Freedom like that's my message once
you're really comfortable in your own
skin and and and you're doing what you
want to do and you're successful and
you're turning heads and people are
taking notice it's a dangerous level of
freedom because it's so easy to be
you know attached to technology and
seeing everyone's opinion on the match
or highlights or anything like that but
I feel like I'm able to really switch
off from that and that's a big part of
my growth I think I feel like once you
get in that cycle of just you know
drinking and drugs just things just pile
up man like that was the biggest thing
for me like once I stopped doing that
everything kind of just fell into place
I was able to sing clearer
and just really get my life back on
track um I just take nothing for granted
anymore like now I wouldn't trade that
for anything the ability to help and
give people confidence is insane and and
and to get out of spots where
you don't want to wake up you don't want
to you know go to work or you feel you
know as a kid I was extremely overweight
got bullied obviously being colored
wasn't easy you know I just feel like
I've overcome so many challenges that I
can just I can get through anything I've
got some really thick skin now and I can
just really help anyone that was my main
goal like that was everything I was
focusing on every day I've got the
platform to help so many people and it
has like I would I just felt guilty like
not using it and not
teaching the younger generation like
there are times where I cross the line
and I'm not going to say that you know
I'm I've always been a good role model
for kids watching like sometimes I do
cross the line but
that's just my passion that's just my
emotion but to everyone right now it's
like all right you can go have a night
out with your friends for sure like
embrace it and enjoy that time but
I would just stop all the all the other
stuff immediately to be honest it's just
it's going to put you in a hole you know
can be able to think clearly and it's
just it doesn't better you at all like I
know it's easy to say it like but it
really doesn't better you at all like
I'm not gonna I've had this conversation
with my girlfriend like if we have kids
like I'm not letting my I'm not letting
my my son or my daughter go out and and
waste time and you know be be peer peer
pressured into doing those things that
just they lead nowhere they lead
absolutely nowhere and I feel like if
you want to you know strive for
greatness or do something outside the
box you can't be doing that stuff for
sure 100 you can tell yourself you've
been here before
you know the confidence and the belief
in yourself that only comes with
achievement
um you know I've obviously met a lot of
a lot of amazing people this year who
have just given me extra motivation and
you know to find people that finally
have my back and that I just love being
around and they just want to push me to
be a better person and and to be a
better tennis player they realize that
I'm immensely talented and I have a lot
of I feel like a lot more to do in this
sport